you were mentioning that your phone is  black and white is there a reason for  that like you've said you never saw the  colors of the podcast room yeah yeah my  phone is in black and white is it  healthy is it better or like what does  that do I bet there's a study there's  got to be a Vanderbilt study done right  so black and white is better on the eyes  or something like that sometimes I go  through faces where it's color but like  I'm in a good phase right now where it's  been black and white for a while yeah  this one's a good one what does it do it  just like keeps me off my phone I'm just  like very addicted to my phone well  everyone is and then also we do it for  our job so just that factor when I'm  scrolling through Instagram stories it's  just not as fun to look at so then you  end up putting it down versus if you are  scrolling with colors just like you  scroll for hours